[Music]
and watch your mouth news oh yes I bet
if I come here often
that's a pick-up line controversy has
sparked over whether or not Trump's
[ __ ] remarks are true I love those
comments I hate him so much I never met
him
so I can't say anything they're just
hilarious because it's not something
he's supposed to be saying but he said
but he says it anyways yeah and I like
how I appreciate the honesty I
appreciate a good president he's not
he's not at all but the funny thing to
me is watching someone like this [ __ ]
[ __ ] act the way he he is in it it's
like making a mockery of our country I
should be embarrassed but for some
reason I'm enjoying this
it's definitely entertaining for sure
that's awesome but I should be kind of
like oh man this is this is a bad look
on us and all that but at the same time
I'm kind of like finally finally we're
getting through to the old guard that's
been [ __ ] up for a long time old
politics now we got somebody in it
trolling really hard well we have a
reality star as a president so what do
you expect we're gonna have reality TV
episodes yeah so if you guys haven't
heard Donald Trump did apparently made
some comments about citizens from the
continent of Africa and the countries of
El Salvador and Haiti I'm gonna play a
clip of the Senators that were in this
meeting so they were meeting for daca
and apparently during this meeting
that's when Trump made these comments
and so their Senators coming at it from
different angles like there's one
senator saying he definitely said this
and another one saying like I never
heard it so I'll show you guys here we
go anyone started to describe
immigration from Africa that was being
protected in this bipartisan measure
that's what he used his file and banker
comments calling the nation's they come
from shippers and you speak about chain
migration it hurts them personally he
said oh that's a good line did not use
that word George and I'm telling you
it's a gross misrepresentation any times
you want me to say that all I can say is
I was in a meeting directly afterwards
were those who had presented to the
president our proposal spoke about the
meeting and they they you said those
words were used before those words went
public
so even Republicans are kind of like
riding on him yeah well kind of it kind
of like sorta saying like yeah well he
didn't really say [ __ ] he said
[ __ ] but I told you I told you
those words that private guys why is any
of this shocking anymore it's not
shocking this just like what the [ __ ] it
was so funny I saw his compilation of
all the time that the word [ __ ] was
used in all the media nobodies you you
would never think that the the news
would be using that word yeah oh yeah
this is Trump tweet that I did not say
[ __ ] hole I said [ __ ] the language
used by me at the daka meeting was tough
but this was not the language used what
was really tough was the outlandish
proposal made a big setback for daca
huge he never said anything derogatory
about Haitians other than Haiti is
obviously a very poor and troubled
country never said take them out made up
by dams I have a wonderful relationship
with patients probably should record
future meetings unfortunately no trust
exclamation what was it was this a
private meeting it was a private meeting
well at least to my knowledge there were
no media outlets are recording the
meeting or anything
so yeah and then also they were saying
that right after he said that like why
do we keep something along the lines of
like why do we keep accepting people
from [ __ ] countries why don't we get
more people from Norway and then that
just like blew it up even more it's like
damn your that race is like no way not
only is he races he's stupid yeah cuz
it's like people from well-established
developed nations don't want to come to
America why would you know there's no
immigration from Japan since I think the
80s because it's like they don't need it
people come to America because they want
to have a better life this is the place
where even European immigrants back in a
day that that was a quote-unquote
[ __ ] country at the time like when I
only had a potato famine or whatever at
the time it was a [ __ ] country
whatever they had to come over
cuz it's like no one wants to leave
their ancestral land no one wants to
[ __ ] leave what they know they come
here cuz they need money you know they
need an opportunity because wherever
they're at there's like the [ __ ]
economy [ __ ] or this war-torn or
whatever how come we can't get any
British immigrants how come all the
super bottled caches move here thought
he was Kevin Spacey for a second just a
little bit obviously a lot of people
chiming in on this and a lot of
celebrity saying like well I come from a
[ __ ] country and I'm proud of it and
things like that so nobody really said
he's denying it someone but that word is
so it's so specific yeah I could totally
hear Donald Trump saying something like
that yeah and it's very specific yeah
you know I mean not terrible not a
shitty its [ __ ] and there's a few
people on his site that's not really
denying it completely so it's like what
do you mean it's like you know what's
funny though well it's not funny it's
pretty sad is we um America specifically
is the reason why some of these [ __ ]
countries exist if you read them I think
it's called memoirs of an economic
hitman I don't know if it's memoirs but
economic hitmen type that in read about
it and this guy is a whistleblower
because he was delivered he was
basically in charge of working with the
world financial bank I think or the
World Bank and their whole thing is to
go after vulnerable nations that need
funding that are kind of destabilized or
date whatever their weaker countries
right poor nations and what they do is
they put them on debt and then they're
like well you know we could we could you
could repay your debt if you just let
our American corporations come in and do
all these other things and they
basically colonize through money so we
keep them [ __ ] up we keep them
destabilized and all that especially
African countries because there's so
many resources there it's in our best
interest if they don't have a strong
government you know basically any of us
can go in and rape all of their
resources your mind their we can take
their oil whatever and it's kind of it's
[ __ ] sad because people see it as
like they can't get their [ __ ] together
because they're not evolved like us
they're not intelligent like us all
these things but that's not the case
it's because they've been [ __ ] so much
to the point where they can't stabilize
yeah and this is not a conspiracy
there's facts out there or like those
charity organizations I want to help and
they just end up giving them everything
and then screwing up the actual vendor
like the merchants and some of them
working cahoots with these guys too it's
[ __ ] sad yeah so you think oh this
organizations so great because they're
coming into this country they're feeding
everyone but they're deliberately
putting them in this welfare state so
people never become independent and
learn how to control their own demand no
they keep them on welfare so they're
constantly dependent on other sources
and people never find independence that
way that's kind of what certain people
have commented on what's happened to
black Americans - yeah like that they've
just been systematically pushed down
throughout like history so they can
always be dependent yeah that's that's
us yeah but what can we do I don't know
I think it's interesting what is
happening right now because people voted
in a troll cuz people were probably sick
of how the world was working and all
that stuff
so wouldn't so now we have someone like
Trump but then it's like whoa [ __ ] man
you might get us in a war I don't know
what is he might get us into big trouble
what do you guys think about everyone
kind of put Oprah up for president I
think that everybody needs to stop
looking at their immediate celebrity
because I know it's like that's the only
people that they know and it's a very
it's a very sad representation of how
people they only think within their
small cluster right so a lot of people
want to talk about reform change
politics what should be done like the
Constitution everything else but they
can't they wouldn't know the first thing
about politics when it came to any of
these things yeah you know what I mean I
guess that's the reason why I voted
Trump because they were like we've done
no but they haven't they have not they
have not done their due diligence if you
ask somebody about politics and
Reformation they can't say anything
aside from an article that they read on
Facebook so what and they're I know a
lot of people personal friends would do
this [ __ ] so they say it's stuff like
that right we've tried no you have not
tried you are the exact same people that
were then before you have done no
research and so you haven't actually
tried so that's the issue that I have -
people are so loud with their words but
they don't even do the due diligence to
do their own research you know what I
mean yeah and so that's why people say
Oprah for president right I mean maybe
she would be I don't know but there's a
lot of people who are probably a lot
better as viable candidates for these
positions that have worked in politics
they actually do know how this country
runs versus just see it from the outside
that could be better I don't know
bothers me a little bit just a little
like you know in passing and reading and
stuff and then people that voted for
Trump they're thinking like yeah you
know we've like I said like they think
that what they've tried the politicians
and that they've they just can't trust
politicians anymore because they're just
so corrupt and they're just so skewed
and they're their perceptions that they
only want what's best for the
politicians not really for the people
but I think it was funny that they're
saying all of that but then they vote
Trump exactly and it's and it's highly
evident when it comes to like you know
when you when you see people get
interviewed and you
you ask them questions about you know
what's going on right now and they don't
know [ __ ]
they just say very blanketing statements
I hate Trump or I like Hillary I thought
that that that but there's no specific
the there's no specificity in the things
that they say because they don't
actually know just like I don't know
that's why I don't talk about politics I
don't know [ __ ]
[Music]